you can see hopefully all the shots
we're providing here there are a number
of coaches that have pulled right up to
the plane here the 747 which landed in
the last half an hour or so the 32
British and EU nationals will be getting
on those coaches what happened at Brize
Norton the RAF based in Oxfordshire when
the other evacuation flights came in
from Wuhan is that that and they didn't
go to any medical facility or building
at the airbase think they got straight
on the coach and we know that these
coaches will have a foreign office staff
on board they will have medical staff
and we've been told that those medical
staff will be wearing the full personal
protection equipment those suits with
the masks and they will sit if it's like
the previous flights those medical staff
will sit at the very front of the
coaches and they'll place the British
Nationals at the rear of the coaches
keeping a separation area then this is
very similar to the plane journey where
they have to keep a certain areas empty
on the plane on the coaches just in case
any of those people start to display
symptoms or say that they are feeling
unwell they have an area there which is
separate from the rest of the group
where they can take them we're now
onboard the plane it was pretty much
like any normal commercial flight we
were told by the Foreign Office that
they had two hot meals they were given
in flight entertainment pretty much what
you would expect on a long-haul flight
at 12 hours or so from Japan and once
they're on board those coaches as I say
they'll be with the medical staff and
they will then start to make their way
up to the world up to arrow Park
hospital that NHS facility which has
been used now over the last month for
other British nationals who've needed to
be kept in quarantine they'll be taken
up there and they will be kept in
quarantine for 14 days a difficult
situation for these people because
they've of course spent 17 days
essentially in isolation on board the
diamond princess in Yokohama and very
difficult conditions on board the cruise
ship many of them obviously been kept
inside a cabin some without windows so
very very difficult conditions there it
will be
a slightly easier ride arrow Park
they'll have the the on suite rooms
they'll have the internet television
access to a small area of outside space
which has been sealed off in this
essentially this block of flats used for
NHS staff which is being converted for
these for this quarantine purpose now so
they will have more facilities and a
little bit more freedom here but
obviously they're facing now another two
weeks even quarantine there and they
simply don't to take any risks because
of course these EU and British nationals
have come off this boat which has had
some 620 confirmed cases of kovat 19
contained within that that cruise ship
so it's a very concentrated and very
large number of people who've contracted
the virus and they just simply don't
want to take any risks with these
British and EU nationals which is why
they then have to have this further 14
days in isolation around an hour or so
we expect it might take them to get them
all all the coaches and then they'll be
heading north drive around for 2 5 4 or
5 hours possibly by police motorcade as
they go up to the world for that
quarantine period
you